hello
welcome to our career webinar the change
landscape of
tech hiring um our
speaker today is vishy shuklov the chief
technology officer of
hacker earth and um
our partner sponsor today is
freshersworld
and this should be an excellent session
whether you are looking
for new hires for your organization or
whether you
want to get hired uh before we start a
little bit about how to work
the webex controls
for questions for vichy which we will
handle at the
end of the webinar session
please use the q a box
remember to address them to all
panelists and
hit send uh you can
put information in the chat if you wish
uh it only gets shown to
us and not to everyone in the audience
use the all panelists setting as well
there
or host and presenter and send
and we'll be able to look at that during
the process but again we will be
collecting the questions to present of
issue toward the end of the session
we'll also be doing polls
and let's start with one
here
and this is basically to get a feeling
for who's in our audience today
and how everybody's coping with the
ongoing
work from home situation
about another 20 seconds to answer
and we'll close the poll in five four
three two one
here are the results
and as you can see
people have tend to have more experience
in this audience
so we have a bimodal distribution of
people with a lot of experience
or people who are still in school
um but the nice thing is that
two-thirds of you are saying everything
is going well today for you
and for the people who did mark thumbs
down we hope that
by the end of the session um you'll have
some information that will help you feel
better
and with that i'm going to introduce
fishy who is as i mentioned the
chief technology officer of hacker earth
14 overall years of work experience
including seven years
at amazon where he started out as a
developer
and ended up as a site leader for one of
their us locations
and has since spent seven years
leading technology teams at various b2b
software as a service startups so he has
a wealth of experience to share with you
today and
welcome vichy
thank you so much stuart looking forward
so one question to start us off with is
how have tech jobs
changed over the last year
or the last year or the last you know
in the horizon we're looking at we're
looking at the last several years and
then everything
changed much faster in the last year
yeah i think
i think if you ask about the nature of
jobs i don't think there's been a lot of
change in the nature of jobs
itself right but but if you ask about
the number of jobs i do believe you know
tech hiring has actually picked up
after an initial uh that we saw
uh during the months right
so so i would say last year february
march
april was was pretty tough uh but
me onwards when people uh figured out
that hey
we are going to sort of learn to live
with this and we've got to get on with
lights
that's when the tech hiring actually
picked up quite a bit
in fact a lot of uh you know quote
unquote non-digital businesses
moved more and more towards digital
mediums right
whether it was for distribution or for
execution or whatever else they wanted
to
and and that has created a whole lot of
new opportunities
for for software developers generally
speaking right so tech hiring
has actually picked up you know i i work
for an organization where we are
directly dealing in tech hiring
for you know a lot of multinationals
smbs and startups
and what we've seen is our own uh you
know
traffic has picked up at least three to
four times right
of our usual traffic so that's the kind
of impact that you've seen in the last
i would say two to three quarters of
these
okay um
what has there been a shift in the tech
roles that employers are looking to fill
yeah i would say there's been there's
been a constant shift towards
you know uh you know organizations
looking for
deeper technical skills right so so
on the job skills and and being hands-on
with a lot of technologies
is something that people actually look
for uh organizations
initially used to spend a lot of time
and
you know energy and resources into
training some of these employees
after hiring them i think that has
has signal change and now they want
people who are actually ready to take up
and you know hit the road running sort
of a thing so so that i think has been a
major change
okay um so
has this changed how employers express
their
job descriptions their requirement
absolutely absolutely so so some of that
in fact
is something that i'm going to talk
about today as well uh but
but yeah i think what has started to
happen is
uh fundamentally how organizations used
to
you know recruit people is undergoing a
major change of major shift
and this this change was uh already kind
of underweight for last several years
uh but because of covet i think a lot of
these things have suddenly
you know fractified in the last nine
months so so
so there has been a major major change
in that aspect as well
uh obviously uh it may not have impacted
everyone
uh so far but people who have been
actively looking for jobs or people who
have been actively interviewing
i think all of those people have been
touched by these changes
um so
qualitatively does that that change
the targeting that people should have in
terms of what they're looking for
on what area of technology they should
be looking to
enter or should they look to shift from
you know from one area of development to
another or from
being a developer to being a devops
engineer
those kinds of things yeah i would i
would say
you know uh there is no dirt of
opportunities in either of these areas
that
called out right so whether you want to
get into devops or you want to get into
web application development
development there's absolutely no doubt
of opportunities in fact
uh there is a slight
quality talent uh that exists there
right so so that is something that
we kind of are working towards ourselves
at hackard and i'm sure there are a lot
of optimizations of trying to solve this
problem
but but there's absolutely no death of
the quality rules that exist for
across you know across the industry for
any of these skills so obviously we hear
a lot about data science
and ai and these things but but to be
honest i mean
uh this is just yet another technology
uh it isn't necessarily going to replace
some of the traditional
uh tech rules as such uh so this is just
an add-on
is what i would say um
you mentioned hacker earth
addressing the imbalance between supply
and demand
of qualified people um can you tell us a
little bit more about
hacker earth what you do how you uh
advance that cause sure sure so
so at hackard we have two or three
facets which are externally facing
uh one is basically a developer
community
which is more than five million strong a
global developer community this
community is typically
you know uh you know engaged in a lot of
hackathons
and a lot of practices that you know we
kind of
offer this is all free of cost you know
anybody can come and sign up for a
practice session with us
so they can practice as many problems as
they want to in whatever
so that's one area hackathons and
challenges are
another sort of area where again
organizations can come and sponsor these
hackathons and challenges or you know
they can uh
they can basically put forth a challenge
or a hackathon which is to evangelize
their own internal technology that they
might have built
right so it could be for any it could be
for a social cause recently we did one
in participation with united nations
right it was
to help the cause of aging right and how
developers can uh basically figure out
solutions uh
and make the you know society more
inclusive towards aged people
right so so there are various various
sorts of hackathons and challenges that
continue to take place
and then the third aspect is the
assessment uh you know
which is basically about uh you know
organizations
and thousands of uh you know candidates
and actually trying to recruit from
those
right so so typically people uh people
come in
and they create a test of sorts and that
is a technical test where people
you know candidates can come in or they
can answer some subjective or objective
questions
and once they have attempted the test
they have gotten a score for themselves
the organizations then decide to take
them further for interviews and
so on so that's that's really awesome
by the way uh on behalf of aged people
everywhere
thank you for your initiative for the
united nations
um this was just the most recent example
it had nothing to do
with who i'm talking to right now
no no i think it's very appropriate um
the uh
uh the hackathons um
and the the the notion of working on um
you know would we include in that the
idea
of um open source development that
is that the environment we're talking
about
yeah where people are yes absolutely
yeah
how would you um how would
you advise people in terms of the
benefit of participating in open source
development projects and hackathons
for getting visibility towards employers
and for building up that credibility um
in your portfolio or your resume i'm
just gonna cover that as part of my
my presentation so so let's see
wonderful
okay good um and
i'm just taking a look at some of the
questions that i wanted to ask you
um so i think one of the things that
we'll
we'll discuss in that in that area
relates to this
this question so i'll ask the question
but i'll let you
answer in the context of your
presentation what steps can candidates
take
to present themselves in the best light
to employers
um the flip side of that is the question
of
how do hiring managers quickly find the
right candidates
um among many applicants and
out in the universe where you're at at
this point competing against
many other organizations for talent
absolutely very very relevant questions
as well so
so you know that is something that i'm
going to talk about
okay well um i think this would be a
great time for you to
begin that presentation so i think uh
yes all right great uh so thank you
everyone for joining in
uh i know it's probably late for some of
you joining from india but
thanks for sparing time during your
evening and and
people from rest of the world if you're
joining uh you know
thanks for sparing time and listening to
me this
i hope uh you know the information that
i'm going to share and my
insights and my experience that i'm
going to share is going to be very very
helpful for you
but uh you know and and obviously we are
going to
keep the q a session towards the data
part so
keep firing in your questions to steward
he'll be
you know moderating those and with that
i'll i quickly
jump on so i don't have a lot of you
know text on the slides per se
so you would probably have to just
listen to me and and follow
follow the slides you know as they move
along but but not a lot of content
on the slides itself right so with that
i'll quickly start
uh stuart i will want you to confirm if
you can see my next slide
all right great so so i want to quickly
start off
you know by by defining what is skill
signaling right
so so typically you know when you are in
the job market you kind of uh
you know are trying to attract uh
companies and recruiters and
you know the entire ecosystem has been
functioning in a certain manner right
so traditionally a lot of this skill
signaling
uh so to say what's being done during
your using your resumes right
so resumes have been the sole carrier of
any kind of information
related to your skills candidates
uh you know usually used to dump all
sorts of information around their skills
you know into their resumes and they do
that because recruiters were using these
skills to
shortlist people based on these resumes
and the skills that were present there
right
so so it's kind of a feedback loop that
that had gotten created
and and the ecosystem was functioning
like that so whether or not the
candidate is confident about their
knowledge of certain skills
they used to take this route to optimize
their chances of success right so
sometimes you
you may know a few languages but you
would kind of increase that list
by your two or three more languages and
you know you would want to kind of just
get
your foot into the door in terms of you
know entering the hiring process right
so that's that's traditionally how
resumes have been used
right and and this obviously uh not only
reduced the conversion rates for
candidates
but it also sent out like i said
feedback signals which were very
misleading
right so that's that's one traditional
way of skill signaling
right slowly as the ecosystem evolved we
all of us started using linkedin
right but there again uh you know except
for some cases like you know the nature
of the information remained pretty much
the same
right just like you have the information
on the resume it was now available on a
website called linkedin
right and i'd agree that using you know
blogs and posts on linkedin or having
recommendations on linkedin
was still a better way of actually skill
signaling
but but anything beyond this was still
pretty much the same
presented presentation format right old
wine new bottle
sort of a thing so uh you know and again
moving on
uh what are some of the other avenues
using which you know we used to do
skill signaling traditionally right it
can be done by calling out your
educational category right so for
instance somebody says hey
i have a degree from stanford or mit or
if you are in india you could
you could basically claim hey i have a
degree from a tiger college like an iit
or something right
and hence i must be better fit than most
of the other candidates in the job pool
well you know it used to be a very
established way of skill signaling
uh we will talk about whether it really
helps
you know your cause or not as of today
right similarly for work experience
right so
so i personally work for amazon and a
lot of
you know good companies out there uh
where people if they work in those
companies it kind of
creates that that you know value on
their resumes
but honestly you know at best this is a
hit or a miss case for hiring manager
when they try to hire based on just this
pedigree
right so so again having a big name on
your resume
may or may not necessarily scale signal
in the right way uh you know
so all of these things right whether it
is resuming or linkedin
or your your educational degrees
or your work experience all of these i
would say
are not your direct signals for skills
rather these are proxies
right so these are proxies for your
actual skills
so so i hope you got some sense of of
what are these proxies that we're
talking about now let's move on to some
of the real skills
you know that real skill signals right
so first one that i wanted to cover
there is contribution to open source
uh projects right and stewart briefly
touched upon this so
so i think uh if as a candidate right uh
imagine having a candidate who's done
open source contributions
uh in his in his life right irrespective
of the depth of those contributions
right even if you have checked in four
or five lines of code into an open
source project
i am assured that as a hiring manager
and trust me when i say this i've
taken thousands and thousands of
interviews and assessed them over
several years right
i as a hiring manager i'm assured that
you actually
you as a candidate actually understand
how development with a team and on a
team project actually works
right uh the candidate must have gone
through a process of
you know getting their prs uh you know
reviewed by somebody else right somebody
who's probably a better and a senior
developer
might have given you a critical high
quality code review feedback for
instance right
all of these are such valuable learnings
for any software developer
so so if you have any signal like that
on your youtube
i as a hiring manager would be super
duper impressed right similarly
if you have a github profile like most
of most of the serious developers these
days have a better profile right
um just by looking at your activity on
github
the hiring managers can figure out uh
whether the candidate has spent
uh quality time on some of those skills
or not right
hiring managers can figure out what are
the real skills that you have what are
the exact
languages that you know about or what
are the frameworks that you
that you have used in past right
similarly looking at the github timeline
of yours
they can actually see how active you
have been in recent weeks or recent
months
again that's a very strong signal
towards your actual coding skills
right or or let's say application
development skills so again
again something with really really
relevant um
again we were talking about hackathons
just a while back uh so what if
the candidate has regularly participated
in hackathons
now to me personally that's a great
signal about candidates
you know ability to actually understand
the real world problems
right uh their ability to actually apply
their technical skills
towards solving real world problems and
that's such a big plus right hackathons
give you that
that unique chance to actually delve
into something which is completely
different
in terms of domain right so you may or
may not necessarily have experience in
that moment
but but you know uh by participating uh
in a hackathon which could be a two
three day event or a week-long
you can learn so much about that
specific domain and
test your knowledge and put your
knowledge to actual use in that moment
right
and this is all done in a very short
span of time so
um so even if you don't end up winning
some of these
uh the exposure it uh you know that this
this kind of exercise gives you
uh you know and and the highly condensed
form of learning that you get
would be very very useful for an actual
job right so this again helps
engineers build business contests
context
and they may lack this otherwise right
if you if you are fresh out of college
you may not have a lot of
domain knowledge in any of these real
life domains
so again something very strong as a
signal
uh the last one that i had was activity
on coding platforms
right so i'll make a confession this is
actually one of my favorite signals
right when i look at the skills uh and
when i'm hiring developers
right so you can sign up on any of these
several online coding platforms hacker
is just one of them right there are tons
of other platforms which are available
to you
you can actually sign up on those pick
any trail
that you want to actually practice on
right so for instance we provide
you know data science as a trail as a
learning path you could pick up any
language
from a series of algorithms or data
structures to actually learn from right
whether it is dynamic programming or
sorting or whatever else that you want
to actually learn
right and these coding platforms
typically have a very
good curation of problems right so you
don't even have to worry
about you know what is the next thing
that you should be picking up right once
you pick up a track
you're pretty much on an autopilot after
that right
and and i think even if you solve a
single problem in a few days
it will give you such a such a dopamine
hit and an immense confidence amount of
confidence
that that you can take up the next one
and the next one and the next one right
once you when once you build that
practice uh right
uh you know if i'm hiring someone who
has mentioned
any of these coding platform links on
their profiles that just shouts out loud
to me that there is actual real skill
over there
right so again i am personally very
biased towards people who
who participate on coding platforms and
actually uh you know
are serious about that so again
something very strong
so so these are you know some of the new
modes of signaling right so so to answer
stewart's question initial question like
what can candidates do
different right to get themselves
noticed i think these are some of those
different things so yes
you do need a resume and you do need an
uh need a linkedin profile
uh you know you need all of that but but
what is going to make you stand out
are some of these right if you're part
in open source projects
if you have a very solid github
contribution you know a profile on
github
if you have profiles on active you know
and activity on coding platforms
if you participate in hackathons pick up
any of these right anything that
interests you
and you would be able to basically
differentiate yourself with vis-a-vis
some of the other candidates which are
there so
so that's that's how uh you know skill
signaling has
changed over time right uh moving on
right so obviously there are a lot of
you know experienced people
who have more than five years experience
on this call right so i will try to
cover
a mix of these skills which will be
relevant for both the entry level as
well as for
for some of the senior folks out here
right so the first one is uh basically
about
uh problem solving now this is one skill
which is basically you know an indicator
of aptitude
right uh or or roughly translated it is
an indicator of your iq
right so can you solve you know problems
by breaking them down
right mapping those problems to
something
that you might have already solved right
it doesn't mean that you should be
solving trig problems or puzzles right
but something that requires more
methodical thinking something that
pushes you to think harder and and build
a thought process right
build your first principles thinking
that kind of thing right
so so what are some of the examples you
know of problems that
that could be kind of uh it could come
under this umbrella right
what if uh you know you are asked in an
interview right how many gas stations
are there in the u.s
right now that's a very very open-ended
problem you as a candidate
might find it very interesting but some
of the candidates actually get
really scared of these problems the the
key is not to get scared and you know
get worried about such open-ended
problems because there is no real
correct answer here uh in most of such
cases
let's say you know the interviewer asks
you how many people commute using delhi
metro every day
right these are very very open-ended
problems and i think what it can be
the interviewer is primarily looking for
in such cases
is whether you have the right you know
ability to think through some of these
very ambiguous problems right and can
you actually arrive at a number which is
remotely closer to
what the real number might be and then
how do you arrive at that for equality
right so your entire thought process
is what matters you may not be able to
guess the number of people who commute
using the metro every day very
accurately which is fine right doesn't
matter but
what is your thought process how do you
arrive at that number is what is
the the interview you're actually
looking for it could be some of the
other
real life problems right so for instance
uh one of the classical problems in
computer
you know computer science is optimal
stopping problem i'm not sure how many
of you have done
in a course on algorithms but but let's
say in real life right
if you were to uh you know answer this
question right
how many houses should you explore
before you finalize something to rent or
buy
right now that's a very real life
problem if somebody's out there in the
market looking to rent a house or to buy
a house
you would typically go on and try to
find out you know
what all houses are available and
whether you like them or not and how
many should you actually
continue to see uh and and then finally
how do you finalize
when to rent and buy which one to
actually finalize right or or some
people who are actually into dating
right so how many people do you date
before you decide
uh you know to marry one of them right
so this is again a classical you know
real world problem but convert it into
you know
an algorithmic problem and it suddenly
uh becomes an optimal stopping problem
right so that's how computer science and
algorithms actually
are used in real life as well and and it
is
your ability to actually map some of
these real world problems into
into what is what you probably would
have studied
you know as part of your courses right
of course uh you know so all these all
these problems actually require like i
said first principles thinking
and they challenge you to think out of
the box right till the time you are able
to think through and you don't get stuck
and you are constantly moving on i think
i think to my mind you're doing
well as a candidate right so that's
about problem solving and aptitude
uh the next one that i wanted to talk
about was basic data structures and
algorithms again very specific to
software development role right
a lot of developers by the way shy away
from these right
even even when they know that this is
important they shy away from these
because they think that you know these
these are problems that are only meant
for books
but in real life you don't necessarily
need this
knowledge well let me tell you with all
my experience that i have seen
you could be more mistaken if you think
like that right a java developer who can
explain to me
how an arraylist class is actually
implemented is far far better
better than the one who actually just
knows how to use that rls class right
so i'm i'm looking for your solid
understanding of
of what is happening under the whole or
you know so that that kind of knowledge
is always helpful
um to give you you know a real life
analogy right
uh you know a soldier can pretty much
dismantle his rifle and reassemble that
rifle in a second
in a matter of few seconds uh they don't
necessarily need to do that in a war
zone but they
still practice that they do that because
if ever
a situation comes where the rifle got
stuck they would be able to service it
quickly and start using it again
right and that's exactly what these data
structures and algorithms do to you
right so no matter how solid you know no
matter
how often or not how often you actually
use these
it is important to have this this
knowledge right and and so that
you know you kind of bring out that
swiss army knife whenever that is
actually needed so knowing your data
structures and algorithms
you know it's pretty much like having a
toolkit which you can flip out anytime
and and just use it when the situation
demands right so again very very
important
skill to have uh the next one is
basically about design now this is this
is
obviously more relevant to people who
have some experience in software
development
right there are typically two types of
designs that that hiring manager you
know test you for
right one is a high level design right
by high level design what i mean is
uh you should basically have the ability
to
architect software systems using various
moving parts
right this is what i personally call
synthesis right so given various parts
let's say i give you a database i give
you a web server i give you a proxy
server
uh maybe i throw in a cache or a
queueing system
right can you actually put together all
of them and and design
the system for me right that is the
architecture
that that typically hiring managers look
for and it's
you know primarily referred to as uh
high level design
right so that's one part of the design
skill the second part of the design
skill is basically
uh low level design right now this goes
squarely back to your
your knowledge about object oriented
principles if
some of you have done those courses
right so can you correctly identify
various entities in a given system right
can you convert those
entities into maybe classes or maybe
database schema with the right
relationships between them
right for example if you were to design
a system to
build simply learn right i'm taking this
example so that most of you can connect
with us right so if you were to design
simply learn
you would have to identify entities like
uh you know
a learner or a course or maybe a cohort
right so these would be different
entities uh typically
a relationship would look like you know
a course has many learners right so
there is a one-to-many relationship
between course and learners
right so these are these are the kind of
relationships that you would have to
identify
and again all of this is clubbed under
low level design so people who have done
software development for a few years
are required to know some of these uh
you know skills
i mean to possess some of these skills
as well
right so that's about uh design
now uh the last one that i had is
actually pretty interesting
now um when you're hired as an engineer
let's say some of you are actually
working as a software developer already
right what might happen is that
not always you actually start uh you
know
working and coding on blank ids right
more often than not you would start
adding code to existing code that
you know which has been written by
somebody else you know it could be a
part of the product it could be part of
some project that is already built out
uh it might have existed for few months
few years maybe right but as a new
engineer on that team
can you actually read through the code
right
and and identify some brittle parts of
that code
something that might be poorly designed
right
or or something that is not correctly
abstracted out right
these are what i call as bad code smells
right or bad smells
right when you start adding more to that
repository you are expected to increase
the overall
code quality and decrease you know and
basically decrease the cyclomatic or
general complexity wherever possible
so if you are looking for jobs as a
software developer make sure you have
these skills make sure you can actually
read code and understand code and
make amends in that code whenever
possible right
how do you do that again i would go back
to the
initial part of my my talk and i would
tell you that hey
go read some code from an open source
library right go explore github there
are lot tons and tons of interesting
projects out there
right so that's how you do uh you know
spot codes in this
okay so so these were some of the skills
you know that that were very obviously
very specific to software development
because that's that's the general
audience that i'm trying to get into
today
um again uh in terms of
upskilling right i mean uh i talked
about various skills now some of
you might already possess those skills
but for
you know whatever whichever part of you
know all those skills you don't possess
to go out and build those right and hone
those over a period of time
and remember that you know it's not a
one-time activity that you do when you
when you pick up a language or you pick
up a you know a framework or you learn a
new algorithm
right it is more about how you can get
into a mode of continuous learning
right how you can continue to invest in
yourself so
so upskilling is more like you know your
second nature then
right that's that's the state you want
to be right
uh quickly wanted to touch upon top-down
and bottom-down learning approaches
right so top-down learning uh basically
means you try to pick up a real-world
problem
and then you basically break it down
into smaller problems
right find solution for those smaller
problems and then finally you convert it
into code or or whatever else
is your final delivery right so that's
your top down problem we talked about
you know let's say uh uh building simply
learn or something like that right so
you start with a high level problem
statement and then you try to
try to break it down right the bottom of
learning would typically involve
you picking up you know data structures
or learning algorithms
right or learning uh various languages
right or related frameworks and then
finally you know building applications
using those
right so those become your building
blocks so you kind of pick up the
building blocks first and then start to
build it out from bottom right
so for instance you want to uh you want
to build a library management system
right
uh you will figure out you know how to
manage records for the books right
library users in terms of algorithms you
may have to learn
right so uh sometimes you might have to
apply sorting to arrange books
right you might have to learn about uh
lru caching strategy
right to place the books in the most
optimal manner so this is
uh this is an example of how you can
break down the system into smaller parts
that are actually
implemented and there's nothing wrong in
picking either of these approaches right
in fact most of the time you are doing
both so some of those things you will
actually do a top-down approach while
the others
you would actually pick up bottoms up so
that's about
uh you know upskilling uh moving on now
from this point on you know whatever i
talk about will be more
sort of generic in nature uh not
necessarily
related to your coding and your
technical skills
right so obviously as a software
developer if you have coding skills you
are great
i mean at least you have a starting
point right but
but what if you know i mean let's say
you can you can
code you write excellent code you can
design and you have learnt your data
structures well
etc but what if you are able to you know
not able to communicate effectively
right any time you know no matter what
organizations you
organization you work for or you want to
work for right
if you cannot communicate verbally or in
writing
i'll be very very candid you're not
going to get too far professionally
right that's the bottom line you have to
have to learn to
effectively communicate sometimes people
think that ability to communicate
effectively you know
is is just about using polished english
or or whatever
other language you might be using right
that's just plain false
effective communicators you know
are the ones who know when to talk what
to talk about
and who to talk to right that is
essentially what effective
you know communication is all about so
once these guys know the criticality of
the situation
and they figure uh these things out uh
who to talk to and
when to and what to talk about right
then it's just execution then it's just
whatever language you are comfortable
with you actually use that and you know
get your job done right but but you know
i cannot over emphasize
uh you know on this aspect that
communication is
is such a key skill that everyone must
and must possess right here's a
challenge for all of you right
try finding any good or great leader
around yourself
who cannot communicate effectively just
try to do that
and let me know towards the end of the
talk if you can figure out
somebody all right so
moving on this is again
something which is very very very
critical
guys and and whether you are looking for
a job
you are already working somewhere uh and
and
you know you have a solid job doesn't
matter right
attitude is something you know that will
always
you know kind of shape your life right
whether it is professional or personal
right
it will shape your life uh someone why
said this once right
talent can open the first two or three
doors for you in life
but it's your attitude that actually
opens the remaining 97
right so so that's what that's how much
attitude actually matters in life
you guys saw in the introduction that i
spent a lot of time at amazon
and and i spent my formative years there
as an engineer
and we used to spend so much time
practicing and preaching these 12 to 14
leadership principles over there right
you can find tons of literature online
for those right
but i have picked these three for you
which you can see in the slide
um which i found very very relevant for
this audience specifically
and trust me if you can demonstrate
these three traits
truly right nobody can stop you from
reaching wherever you want to in your
career
right it's it's as important as that um
so with that i'll move on to the first
one which is ownership
now the thing with ownership is it is
basically about taking
charge right so do you take complete
charge of the things that you are
required to work on
do you act like maybe you own the
company or do you act like ceo of your
function or
or your your basically your area or your
component or whatever it is that you are
responsible for
right so so do you act like an owner or
do you act as if it's your own business
right uh do you step in for colleagues
when you see them slipping
right or or do you you know do you step
in when you see something slipping
through the tracks
right that's what is ownership
essentially right it starts from simple
things
like uh if you write code uh then do you
test your own code
right or do you review your own code
right or or let's say if you're
in a non-coding environment then do you
talk to the stakeholders and ensure that
everything
is as per what they wanted right and
people with high degree of ownership
stand out because we can we all can
simply bank upon them to deliver it
right
if if you tell me that hey this person
this xyz person has high degree of
ownership
i will be able to trust them with what i
need them to deliver
right so these these are the peoples who
people whom you don't have to really
follow up with on anything
right you just give them something and
and basically consider it done
right that's that's what ownership
essentially means very very very
important trait for anybody in
their professional lives uh the second
one is uh let's say hunger for
excellence right
now this is basically about pushing the
bar higher every time
right so again i'll give you an example
let's say when you work out right
you count your reps right let's say you
start with 10 reps but slowly
you know you keep building your stamina
and you go for 15 then you go for 20
you'll go for 30 and 40 and so on right
so what are you doing you're essentially
pushing yourself and you're pushing the
envelope to perform better every time
right with every single instance you're
actually performing better
and that's exactly the regimen that you
need to follow with your work too
right so so let's say if you if you are
a developer and
you you know in your 100 lines of code
you get five comments every time
uh see how you can reduce that to one
comment or a zero comment
right similarly if you write a technical
design document which requires a lot of
back and forth
see how you can uh get absolutely
uneventful design reviews right
similarly if let's say you are you are
into some business uh
role let's say you uh you are writing a
case study right
and that case study has to be reviewed
by by your stakeholders
see how uneventful that review is right
can can you just smoothly
sail through that review and not get any
comments right and if you get then how
do you improve the next time onwards
right
so that's exactly what hunger for
excellence is and i think
people have some people have a natural
knack
for pushing themselves while the others
need to nurture this right so that's the
difference you you have something as
your nature versus
something that you need to nurture and
both of them are fine till the time you
actually realize the importance of this
right so that's that's hunger for
excellence
the last one that i picked out of
everything you know that i have kind of
gone through
uh is customer uh obsession so again
no matter what organization you work for
you know whatever role you are applying
for or you are already working for right
customers will always take the top
priority
right that is the bottom line so you
have to put the customers needs first
and work backwards from there right this
essentially means that
uh maybe if you are an engineer uh you
know you might be pulled off
from your plant tasks right or your role
would be anything right you might have
planned your week out
but then suddenly there is a customer
need for which you might be pulled off
pulled out of that plant task and and
you might be required to work on
something
uh something as in that that basically
resolves customer pay
and that's absolutely fine right this
could mean that you pick something which
has very tight deadlines for instance
right
so you might be required to to deliver
something to a customer
in a very short span of time this is all
very
very uh you know sort of regular right
this this happens
uh fairly uh commonly right fairly
frequently
so uh any organization which is which
cares about its customers and honestly
if you don't care about customers you
see
it seems to be an organization after a
point in time
right so so this could mean you know
let's say if you're a business facing
uh person right this could mean taking n
number of customer calls by doing
product demos or explaining them how
things work
right and this could require you to work
on ours this could require you to
require you to work weekends right so so
etch this
on your minds that customer is truly the
king or the queen
right and we all when we work under the
organization are working to serve them
right and that's the very reason why any
business actually exists
right so so these were the three things
that i wanted to kind of touch upon
in terms of you know uh
what should be uh you know constituting
your
attitude per say right so ownership uh
hunger for excellence
and and uh customer obsession so i think
uh with that i
have kind of uh reached my life last
slide
and this is something that i wanted to
you know talk to hiring managers about
i'm not sure if
the people here are into hiring or they
are hiring
uh anybody or specifically hiring
developers right
so you all know hiring good engineers
quickly is
is very very competitive and it is
actually very hard right
sometimes you may not have the time to
actually uh hire enough people
sometimes you might be you might have
time but you may not have the resources
to pay
good engineers right so it's a very hard
activity
right uh one of the things that i've
always advised young hiring managers
is that you need to always cast a wider
net right
and you can do that because of
technology if i were to take my own
personal example
i used to review you know tens or maybe
hundreds of resumes every month
right uh to hire for a few roles now
uh if i were to sort of avoid that route
how do i do that right
today there are platforms like hackers
which are available where you can go and
basically shortlist
uh you know from thousands and tens of
thousands of candidates who can take a
test
and from there you shortlist whoever you
want to basis the performance on
of those candidates and then take them
forward for interviews right
so it's as simple as that in a matter of
few hours you don't even need to look
into resumes right
you just push uh you design a single
test push it out to maybe 10 000
20 000 we have had organizations uh
you know uh who have assessed more than
70 80
000 candidates in a matter of few hours
right so that's the kind of scale that
you can achieve with technology
so cast a wider net and assess as many
candidates as you want to and then
obviously take them forward
right lastly you know objective hiring
is is the real effective hiring right so
so
if you are if your judgment is based on
too many subjective
signals it will always be a hit and miss
right i covered a few such signals
during the initial part of the talk
right things like
a pedigree educational degree all of
those things kind of
give you uh you know proxy signals
so if you have very objective ways of
identifying skills always go for that
and and that will ensure that you've not
made the wrong outfit
so with that i would stop and steward
for
you
so um i really appreciate that
advice i mean a couple of thoughts that
occurred to me one of
one of which was in problem solving
which has always been
um one of the the skill areas i think is
most important
i was reminded of the old um saying from
uh school days of show your work i mean
basically that you want to
demonstrate that not just that you can
come up with an answer but how you can
come up with an
answer because sometimes that's more
important as you said than getting an
accurate answer we have a number of
uh questions from the audience and
start with some of those i know that we
don't have enough time to handle
all of them but i would like to say
um let's see
what krishna pata
asks what is the best way to skill
signal for a person with
15 years of experience
sorry what is that can you come again
dude the
the audience member asks what is the
best way for someone with 15 years of
experience
to skill signal when looking for
so guys i mean uh you know
it doesn't matter what amount of
experience you have right what matters
is what you've done in those many years
right so if you've done something which
you're truly proud of
those are your skills right uh and and
you can't really change you
go back and change your past so whatever
skills you have picked up in those 15
years
those got to be out there in front but
beyond that if you feel that there is
uh you know something that is lacking go
for it right i mean don't don't let your
work experience sort of hold you back
right even today
you know uh i i try to find time
to learn some new language right and and
we are happy to
you know work with so many different
languages and frameworks
that you know it is imperative for me to
keep myself updated right
so so it's important that that you
continue to pick up and don't
let your work experience come in your
way of trying to learn further
so that's what i would say
um interesting question from
let me ask what would you advise to
people
returning to work after a break like a
maternity leave
so no advice really i mean i think
uh the word is changing right uh there
are
a lot more takers and people are a lot
more open generally speaking
uh and and they don't necessarily mind
till the time you can explain that break
to them
right and and if it's let's say a
maternity break uh
i think most of the organization in
these days actually
uh find it okay but again that
that will not cover for your skills
right so that cannot be used as a cover
up
you have to have the skills that are
required for the job because the job is
not going to consider whether you got
into a possibility
or something else right so till the time
you have the right skill set
there is nobody stopping you from
getting there you might
you might find a few hard organizations
few recruiters who are hard to deal with
and they don't want such candidates
but continue to try on i'm pretty sure
there are there are tons of
opportunities out there
if you just have the right skills
asks uh an interesting question
and you might want to um address the
assumption behind the question
is the uh the question is what are some
hot areas
of new technologies that are good to
work in usually
new hot technologies don't require too
much experience
because they're new and only require
maybe overall technical experience
what would you say yeah so if you want
to learn something which is art and
which is talked about these days
you know go for it i mean see if your
intent is to land a job
then i'm not sure if if that's the right
approach
right but if your intent is to actually
go to learn something new which is hot
out there you know go for it that should
not stop you and if you land a job
while learning something new uh so be it
i mean you are lucky
but but don't think that you know you
will pick up something in a matter of
a few days and and you know land a job
just due to that
that just does not happen right so so
if you if you want something which is
truly worth your time
if a job that if you need a job that is
truly worth your
you know while then you've got to put in
the hard house right
and and learning something hot means
even if you want to have a decent amount
of knowledge i would say
it would take about at least four to six
weeks of solid work and practice
to get there um
durrani asks what role does academic
achievement
play in recruitment um compared to
technical skill
and i think you you addressed this in
your presentation but uh
my question didn't come back up yeah so
so look i mean
if you if you have a degree from a tier
one college uh
some some recruiters might just ring you
up like that
right but but eventually do you land a
job i think
it's it's still largely a function of
what skills that you have really picked
right
so whether or not you went to a tier one
college or an ivy league college
right i don't think it matters a lot and
honestly
even those even that higher education
system is honestly
undergoing a lot of change as we talk
right
so so platforms like simply learn here
or even platforms like let's say
lambda school in the us right or massage
school in india what they are doing is
they are basically picking up a set of
technical skills and they are picking up
candidates uh
you know from wherever these guys are
available and they are coaching them for
three to four months
and once the guys have skills they
actually you know apply to any of these
uh you know top-notch product
development companies right tech
companies
and they get through right in fact
companies like google have stopped
looking at your academic credentials
altogether
right so so i think over period of time
slowly
higher education itself will actually uh
fundamentally change
and and a lot of democratization is
going to happen in that space in the
past
one of our youtube viewers asked about
about
just that question about why industry
experience industry skills aren't
generally taught in universities
and one comment i can make from from the
simpler learn side is that
you know we've actively been forming
partnerships with a number of
uh world world-class universities so
that
they can actually offer
this type of skills education skills
training
and learn by doing hands-on experience
to their to their students so
um you know we work with purdue
university
mit caltech
among many others so the universities
are
looking at that as a gap in what they
offer
and they're trying to fill that um a
number a couple of questions came in
from project managers
um how is the project management
um recruiting processor hiring landscape
changed and
what should project managers do to get
notice
and showcase showcase their you know do
the skill signaling you've discussed
yeah
yeah so so i think uh personally
speaking
the project some of the really really
good project managers that i have worked
with
uh have have had two very key qualities
uh one is obviously they is their
communication
right because your key job is to
actually talk to stakeholders and get
everything moving
and resolve bottlenecks and keep you
know
uh keep the ball rolling essentially
right and that can only be done
if you are a super smart communicator
and super effective communicator right
so that's
one and if you can't do that very
effectively
try to pick that that's you know the
second thing that i have realized
is that project managers who have skills
outside their project management domain
right so for instance a project manager
who
understands sport right he may not be
able to write that code himself but if
he can understand even 10 to 20 percent
of what it takes to write code
and the technical challenges related to
it i think we'll be
a much much better project manager
because we'd be able to
understand them and empathize with the
stakeholders much better
right and similarly if a project manager
is dealing with let's say product
managers
or sales people right if he understands
their word really well
i think the empathy is natural and
we have a couple of questions about
career transitions
and um one is from someone in the
military
uh working in i.t total experience of 20
years
what skills should they
focus on acquiring or highlighting
when they look at moving into the
corporate world or the private sector
yeah
so so i would say you know if you have
been in the military for for so many
years
you probably will crack the attitude
part of it automatically you have the
required discipline and
that has been faked right all you need
to do is
put in maybe six to eight weeks of
effort and pick up one coding language
could be java could be pc could be a
javascript could be any
language right pick up one skill and
pick up one language
and learn that language properly and
then start applying i think
i think the word is yours and then their
focus i think is on project management
because they were
mentioning skills like prints and pmp
and it'll that type of thing
which is which is fine so if you are
into product project management pick up
things like jira
or other project management tools like
asana you know those things right
so anything which is required for the
job pick up one of two of those
those tools and and practice them and
and once you are comfortable you start
applying i think
the good part about you know being in
military is that you have a lot of
hands-on experience in dealing with
difficult situations
and i think some of these project
management skills
are kind of uh you know you know sort of
baked into that kind of job role already
right so i don't think you need to
sort of scale up a lot but but just just
to be aware of the ecosystem
or just just get the hands-on experience
of some of those tools and i think you
can start
looking after we have that
question from annapurani who has
six years of experience which is two
years of
net development and uh four years in
sales
in a tech company and they're looking to
trans um
transition into a business analyst role
um
i mean are there particular things that
they should be
conscious of or trying to add to their
skill set
or yeah so so business analysts
in my experience have been you know
skilled at a couple of
uh you know things and that has been
primarily around
you know either you know how to use uh
sql right and you can query databases
very effectively i think that's one
still that you could definitely pick up
right uh you should have some experience
working with
data visualization tools like tableau or
or something else like that there are
other
open source tools available as well for
data visualization
so if you can take a bunch of data and
actually create visual extensions and
charts
on top of it gather insights from that
data i think that is one skill that
that will definitely help you
and um i think we have time for this
last question
which is just simple which is you know
what are a few coding platforms among
the ones that you look at
yeah so so i think happy earth is
definitely one of those
like i said we have more than five
million people who come and practice on
our platform
but beyond that you know a simple google
very good would tell you
where to go right so uh i don't want to
name names here but but there are quite
a
lot that's fine
okay um and i apologize to everyone
whose questions we didn't have time for
um but we have reached the end of our
of our hour so let me um
just take back the sharing
and wanted to thank you
issue for a really wonderful
presentation
and and conversation um which i've
enjoyed
a great deal and i hope our audience has
as well
and
i want to do a exit poll
which will um
ask people about uh upskilling
and and reskilling and lifelong learning
so
let me open this real quick again just
45 seconds
but of all the
the skills out there and the ones that
this you mentioned and people asked
about
um which ones interest you most and then
we all want to do these things but are
you planning to do them or
are you just dreaming of them so
another 15 seconds
and we'll close the pole in five four
three two one
i'll share the poll results
and data science and machine learning
are certainly popular but there's kind
of a rounded uh
interest across the different fields but
what's an interesting
section how many people said right away
more than half of you said that if you
want to learn the skills
the best time to start is now so um
that's okay yeah that's one very
encouraging isn't it
absolutely absolutely i think i think
there is no better time to start on a
new journey
you know then now so so get started
and we want to again thank you vishu for
this excellent presentation and
here's your linkedin information if
people want to connect
um and
what we're going to do now is thank
freshers world
for helping sponsor this
event today and they
are complementary to what hacker earth
then
simply learn do because they help you
find
work and are
leading a leading job portal in in
india and finally
a quick mention of our skill up program
which is a free program
um it gives you access over a thousand
hours of video content
does not include our live classes but
this is a way to
look at skill skill content from simply
learn
get a feel for it acquire some new
skills
and maybe decide in an
area to move on to so i encourage all of
you to look at that and i've dropped the
link a couple times in the chat and
finally i will
mention our next webinar
it's very interesting one with an
executive laura hendricks from first
horizon bank
in the u.s and
what in the world uh your path to
becoming an expert in
robotic process automation and process
improvement
and what in the world is is the question
she says she asks herself every day when
a new problem comes up that
her team has to to solve
so again another uh great session on
problem solving coming up one week from
today and with that we conclude the
webinar today and i want to thank you
all for being here
and this will be the time
for us to end the session and log off
thank you bye-bye
bye